Aujourd’hui les amis, nous allons piéger un chat !
Et oui, vous avez très bien entendu.
Toutes les caméras sont en place. Je sens qu’on va se fendre la poire.
Team Foufou !
C’est parti !
Voyons-voir si Félix se rend compte du subterfuge.
Regardez les mecs, je crois qu’il se dirige vers sa gamelle !
Et oui, les amis. Nous avons au préalable changé les croquettes de Félix.
Félix est un très grand fan des croquettes au goût saumon.
Va-t'il se rendre compte que celles-ci ont été remplacées par des croquettes goût poulet/boeuf ?
Il est en train de les manger!
Et oui, ce n’est pas gagné les amis !
Felix peut encore se rendre compte que ce ne sont pas ses croquettes.
Il ne s’en est pas rendu compte !
Que dalle !
Il les a carrément avalées !
Les amis si vous aimez le risque, je vous conseille de vous cramponner pour ce qui va suivre..
Voici Sinbad, le colocataire de Félix.
Voyons maintenant jusqu’où nous pouvons  piéger Félix.
Tu m'entends, Dustin ?
Ouais les mecs, je viens de me mettre en position.
Il est tellement obligé de te prendre pour Sinbad !
Tu devrais penser à une reconversion si jamais tu venais à perdre ton job.
Arrête de déconner Jeff, c'est plus le moment.
Attention, Félix se rapproche.
Il est en train de le fixer dangereusement là !
Ne bouge surtout pas, Dustin. Ne bouge surtout pas.
Tente de te lécher la patte !
Les chats font souvent ça !
En effet, Jeff a raison. Les félins, de type "chat", utilisent leur langue pour se toiletter.
Voyons-voir si ça va marcher.
Ça a marché !
P***** ! C'était incroyable !
Bien joué, mec !
Le stress, parce qu'il me regardait carrément dans les yeux.
Comme quoi, y a pas que les chats qui retombent toujours sur leurs...
Pattes !
C'est une mission accomplie pour la Team Foufou !
Encore une fois, tout le monde n'y a vu que du feu.